-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
According to a new report,
Chinese President Xi Jinping
assured President Biden
during their in-person meeting
in November
that China would not interfere
in the upcoming
U.S. presidential election.
Great. You know this election
is going to be the worst
even when countries that
interfered in previous ones
are like, "We good."
President Biden is set to fly
to Michigan tomorrow
for a campaign event hosted
by the United Auto Workers.
But if they ask, he drove.
Billionaire hedge-fund manager
John Paulson
is set to hold
a fundraiser tomorrow
for former President Trump
at his $110 million
Palm Beach mansion.
Why is that guy
doing a fundraiser?
You clearly have funds.
Just give him the money.
It's like if you tried to borrow
some money from Smaug,
and he said,
"Well, we could do a car wash."
California Governor Gavin Newsom
announced new measures yesterday
to restore the state's
salmon population,
and it's a little suspicious
that he announced
it right after meeting
with these lobbyists.
Authorities in Connecticut
recently arrested a man
after he allegedly stole
an ice-cream truck
with $30,000 worth
of product inside.
He faces up to 10 years
in prison
with zero chance
of being pardoned.
A horse in Ohio recently tested
positive for methamphetamine,
in case you're wondering
how they make Krazy Glue.
[ Audience groans ]
I'll wait till
everyone's done being sad.
IBM has reportedly
told its U.S.-based managers
that they must report
to work in person
at least three days a week
or leave their jobs,
which is pretty rich
coming from the people
who basically invented
the personal computer.
You're the ones who made it
so easy to work at home.
That would be like Ford saying,
"You know,
we'd really prefer people
came to work by horse."
Two men who were stranded
on a kayak in the Gulf of Mexico
were rescued this week
by a Carnival cruise ship,
but there was improv that night,
so they asked to go back.
And, finally,
in honor of Valentine's Day,
Starbucks launched
two new drinks yesterday --
the chocolate-covered
Strawberry Crème Frappuccino
and the Chocolate Hazelnut
Cookie Cold Brew.
And just like
your first Valentine,
they'll break your heart.
And that was
the monologue, everybody.
We are off and running.